the movie starts with the protagonist
Craig introducing his hometown of Harlow
Maine it is a picturesque village with
only a few Prime places nothing really
happens here and all the people are
boring as he narrates the story we learn
that Craig is moved away from Harlow in
the present and is recounting his time
spent there as a child during the early
2000s he also talks about the weird
experiences he went through in his
hometown the movie then flashes back in
time where it is revealed that Craig
lost his mother when he was still a
young boy he still blames himself for it
however the cause of death is not
mentioned next we are introduced to a
local billionaire and the richest man in
Harlow Mr Harrigan being a devout
Christian he regularly visits the church
and prays to God one day when he sees
Craig reciting a story he is greatly
impressed so the same evening Mr
Harrigan visits Craig's place with an
offer he wants the young boy to read him
books of all kinds as he is losing his
eyesight in return Craig will be paid
five dollars an hour for his service
unsurprisingly the LA matter accepts
without any hesitation on the first day
of the service Craig is astonished to
see the Billionaire's grand villa it
appears to have all the luxuries one
could wish for but despite having over
50 rooms only two more occupants a
gardener and a maid live there after a
while Craig greets the old man and
starts reading a book to him he
continues doing so three times a week
the old man also provides Craig with
some lottery tickets as a bonus although
Craig had agreed to take up the work
initially for the money he grows a
strong and caring bond with Mr Harrigan
over the next five years after getting
to know the billionaire personally Craig
also has an interest in knowing who
exactly he is so one day he goes to an
internet cafe and looks up Mr Harrigan
it turns out the old man used to be a
businessman with a record of workers
complaining about his strong-willed
nature surprisingly some of them were so
fed up with his ruthlessness that they
even committed the unthinkable however
this doesn't affect Craig's view of the
old man and he continues reading him
books novels the movie then skips by a
few more years and now Craig has become
a teenager he starts attending high
school at a popular institution outside
the city unfortunately Craig runs into
trouble when he makes eye contact with a
bully named Kenny on the very first day
of school during the lunch break Kenny
approaches Craig and casually asks him
to polish his shoes when the latter
refuses Kenny becomes a little too harsh
on him thankfully before things can
escalate the science teacher Miss Hart
intervenes later that week Craig has a
word with Mr Harrigan about the incident
the old man advises him that he should
always deal with the bullies harshly be
it at school or in business as he
himself had faced after getting familiar
with a relatively new social life in the
new school Craig realizes the importance
of smartphones as almost a social
currency the high school cafeteria where
all the cool and Rich Kids meet is
divided by the types of phones that the
students carry for instance the group
with the iPhones is a bunch of
douchebags is considered the coolest
wanting to fit in with this crowd Craig
asked for an iPhone from his father
unfortunately the old man immediately
refuses stating a teenager should only
focus on his studies but on Christmas
Eve Craig receives another lottery
ticket as a bonus gift from his employer
Mr Harrigan when he scratches it he
finds out he has won a whopping three
thousand dollars to make his day even
better his father finally gets him an
iPhone as a Christmas gift feeling
ecstatic with the gifts he got Craig
uses his new iPhone to call Mr Harrigan
first to thank him for the lottery
ticket that he had won they chat for a
while before calling it a night the
following day at school Craig excitedly
shows off his new phone to his friends
he then goes to the cafeteria to join
the cool kids where his Crush Jennifer
is seated next in a voiceover Craig
reveals that he has developed an
understanding that his old employee is
lonely and helpless without him and he
too perhaps feels warm while spending
time with Mr Harrigan it is out of all
these feelings that he decides to give
an iPhone similar to his to the old man
not just to introduce him to the new
technology but all analysis so that they
can keep in touch with each other from
wherever therefore Craig buys the phone
and politely gives it to his employer
this is some Steve Jobs propaganda right
here initially Mr Harrigan denies
keeping such modern objects close to him
he believes that he will become addicted
to them however Mr Harrigan is quickly
swayed over by the phone when Craig
shows him the process of live tracking
stock prices he can also read up to date
news unlike newspapers that inform news
a day late over the next few weeks Craig
teaches him new things that can be done
with a smartphone Mr Harrigan becomes so
invested in the device that he even
loses interest in the books that Craig
reads for him he simply keeps scrolling
through his phone the entire day James
Joyce is cool and all but have you seem
to put Duncan donks on Tick Tock as days
pass we see Mr Harrigan getting caught
up with diseases as he has to wear
oxygen masks at night unfortunately
tragedy soon strikes as one morning when
Craig visits the huge house as part of
his routine he finds Mr Harrigan lying
dead from his own the age-related
sickness since the two housekeepers are
on leave he panics and calls his dad and
the latter advises him to stand by until
help arrives till then Craig with tears
in his eyes reads a book for his close
friend One Last Time cut to the next
scene Craig his father and a few
Community people gather together for Mr
harrigan's funeral the teenager is
devastated after losing his companion
but he still manages to read some of his
favorite books he then decides to
secretly put Mr harrigan's phone inside
The Corpse's clothes before it is buried
soon after the funeral Craig and his
father are approached by Mr harrigan's
personal finance manager they learned
that the old man has left craig a large
sum of eight hundred thousand dollars in
his will to help him with the cost of
higher studies overwhelmed by such a
grand fortune and also out of genuine
love and respect for the deceased man
Craig leaves a voicemail on Mr
harrigan's phone he admits that he would
give up the entire sum if he could just
have his old friend back Craig also
leaves a text message mentioning how he
misses the time they spent together this
is when things start to get unnatural
the following morning Craig gets a reply
which is a very cryptic message from Mr
harrigan's Number startled by this
strange happening he informs his father
about it but the old man firmly believes
that someone must be playing tricks on
him when Craig cannot take such an
explanation and insists on digging up Mr
harrigan's grave in hopes of finding him
alive his father clarifies the situation
apparently the old man was alone that
day and due to extreme boredom he died
of a heart attack the autopsy results
verified this after an intense body
checkup hearing this Craig comes back to
his senses and takes his father's words
as the days pass by Craig continues
grieving his loss but he doesn't stop
going to school one day when the local
bully Kenny is selling narcotics he is
caught red-handed and expelled
unfortunately he wrongly assumes that
Craig was the one who snitched on him so
on the annual event day he sneaks inside
the school premises and beats up Craig
however despite all this the latter
still doesn't report it to the
authorities instead he talks about it on
voicemail to Mr harrigan's Number
obviously not expecting anything to
happen but only as a means of sharing
his grief but to everyone's surprise
Kenny is soon found dead in an accident
although it was reported that the bully
was heavily drunk and had fallen from
his second story bedroom we see his body
with a can of shoe polish in his hand
and some Polish smeared on his mouth
this is eerily interesting because in
the very first interaction that Craig
and Kenny had the bully had threatened
Craig to either polish his shoes or eat
the whole thing meanwhile Craig loses
his mind as he now firmly believes that
the ghost of Mr Harrigan killed the
bully shaken up to the core he
researches more into Mr harrigan's past
and finds out about a man who was once
employed by the billionaire but was
fired after he was apparently caught
stealing a few days later this man was
also found dead just like many of the
other employees who worked for Mr
Harrigan over the years Craig is at a
loss for words because he believes his
former close friend was evil he also
decides to change his phone number by
buying a new one however he keeps the
old phone as it is the first one he ever
had for a while everything seems fine as
Craig graduates high school and gets
into college for a journalism course in
Boston he narrates that he is doing
quite well in his studies but suddenly
his father calls him one day to give him
another shocking and sad bit of news it
turns out that his high school science
teacher Miss Hart was tragically killed
in an accident during his high school
days Craig had grown close to the
teacher as she was the only one who gave
him support and Company during his times
of trouble Craig then returns to his
hometown and learns that Dean Whitmore
the man charged in this accident had
been drinking and driving he was also
previously arrested for drunk driving
although Craig and the other students
want Dean to be punished for his
Reckless Behavior the court lets him off
the hook by simply ordering him to go to
rehab for six months enraged that
Justice was not served Craig decides to
take matters into his own hands he
recalls the unusual Supernatural power
he possesses and with that wasting any
time he leaves a voicemail to Mr
harrigan's Number requesting the murder
of Dean Whitmore the very next day Craig
feels bad about his actions and hopes
that no one gets hurt he also keeps
checking the internet to see if Dean is
alive unfortunately his worst fears come
true as Dean has discovered dead in the
shower of The Rehabilitation facility
where he was staying now that he is
completely aware of what is taking place
Craig freaks out even more he also
begins to comprehend that he is
technically to blame for the murders of
two people Dean and the bully Kenny
Craig just watched death note and he's
freaking out after coming to this
Revelation Craig visits Mr harrigan's
home and starts searching for any clues
that appear Supernatural he doesn't find
much in the room but when he opens a
secret closet he discovers old pictures
of Mr Harrigan Craig had always
questioned Mr harrigan's decision to
hire him over some of the other boys
some of whom were better readers for the
position now he has finally got his
answer just like him Mr Harrigan also
lost his mother at a very young age and
this is why he prefer heard Craig over
the others in the next scene Craig
visits the graveyard and starts talking
to Mr harrigan's grave he claims that he
now understands the cryptic texts he had
received from the old man's number it
actually meant Mr Harrigan was asking
Craig to stop contacting him the main
reason for this according to Craig is
either that Mr Harrigan was being hurt
by these reach outs because he was
unable to rest peacefully or that he did
not want Craig to get hurt because the
young boy was actually entering a mental
state of anger and retaliation after the
visit to the Grave his old phone the
last means of communication between him
and Mr Harrigan is finally thrown into
the lake this puts an end to their
paranormal discussions for good Craig
also wants to get rid of his existing
phone but is unable to do so because
cell phones have become such an integral
part of Modern Life what a moral the
movie ends with another narrated
background where Craig expresses his
desire to be buried with empty Pockets
after his death precisely meaning that
he doesn't want anything especially
mobile phones
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching